hi my name is Vidal Shaz me I'm an
eighth grade senior at Maho bridges
Academy on my way home one day a guy
named Brandon stopped me on the street
and asked me if he can interview me for
his blog he asked me who inspired me in
my life and I said my principal is Lopez
we raised over 1.4 million dollars in a
week or two and next Thursday were going
to Harvard
large majority of our scholars come from
the housing development from this
particular area which is Brownsville
Brooklyn
they've depicted Brownsville as one of
the poorest neighborhoods in New York
City we're known as the impact zone
because there's so many other schools so
it tends to be a large number of
incidents crimes physical aggression
however when you come here and you look
beyond the children here aren't evil
they don't kill they don't rob you know
they're innocent individuals so it's
like almost A Tale of Two Cities usually
ronzo
it's really a Hope College kind of some
people have felt oh don't have the money
to go to college my mom she didn't go to
college and my fault dang go to college
so I want to be the one in my family to
go to college education to me is a form
of empowerment you don't have to have
riches but you can share history you can
share knowledge that can break cycles of
what I consider generational genocide in
which children are ending up in prison
or they're ending up dead because they
just don't know that they are worth
anything more that there's value to
their life
I have no doubt about me going to
college because when I go to college I'm
gonna practice medicine and I want to be
a football player because I like
football I like contacting using all my
energy if that doesn't work out like
video games like technology and stuff
like that song maybe a video game is on
for me the goal of our trip to Harvard
on April 2nd really is around starting
the dialogue and preparing our children
who will ever take them there who will
ever give them that experience in that
exposure and I wanted them to know that
they have options wait until it's too
late and I want the conversations to be
more about how do we develop the
pipeline and set colleges and
universities as opposed to how do we
stop the children from going into prison
if you love creating discovering
exploring building you are going to love
college when you wanted you work hard
for it this is your race because you
deserve to be in the space and you are
now opening up that door creating a
legacy for those who will come behind
you
I want to be a OBGYN I want to major in
culinary arts and minor in business
architecture and design and have my own
architecture engineering firm if you go
to college you're gonna have a good
degree and you got to have good job I'm
gonna stay in school graduate agree to
graduate high school and go to college
education makes a difference in
education of my passion so it's
important that you guys are thinking
about your future it's important if you
guys take trips like this you don't let
anybody happen to the college is meant
to uncap I think is overlooked DejaVu I
think I wanted them to be able to see
that it was possible for them to walk on
this ground and not shying away and
feeling as though they didn't belong
coming here does make me want to come to
college because it gives you the
opportunities to do stuff that lets you
start your comfort zone and I'm going to
make it happen by studying really hard
and listening to my parents
Islands with others just like cramming
straight cramming studying everything
just studying and I saw us I got a lot
of fun it's like a lot of things you can
do here so I think I really want to go
to college now right more than I did
before
I just feel proud
that
all this came from people that care
about how you turned out to be